من جانبه قال فيدانت باتيل نائب المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه قال ان قطر تعد
شريكا اقليميا اساسيا للولايات المتحده لا
يمكن استبداله فيما يتعلق بالصراع الحالي
في غزه جاء ذلك ردا على سؤال عن التسجيل
المنسوب لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو بشان قطر حيث شدد نائب المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه على ان بلاده
تتطلع لمواصله تعميق شراكتها مع
قطر ليس لدي اي تقييم بشان تلك التعليقات
او بعض المقاطع الصوتيه التي تم تداولها
ما يمكنني قوله هو ان قطر شريك اقليمي
اساسي لا يمكن استبداله ليس فقط فيما
يتعلق بهذا الصراع الحالي ولكن ايضا
بالاولويات الاخرى التي لدى الولايات
المتحده في المنطقه نتطلع الى مواصله
تعميق شراكتنا والعمل معها بشان عدد من
القضايا
الرئيسيه